all right we are at San Diego comic-con
Scott Snyder the writer a few things but
we're going to talk a lot about all-star
batman so first question because we
don't have a lot of time how is this
going to be different from your previous
Batman and the other current Batman
books well it's definitely it's very
different I mean the way it came about
and it's great to talk to you again dude
I talked to this guy like every year for
what like seven years now crazy long
enough not long enough food but anyway I
was working on Batman with Greg and I
realized i still had some big villain
stories i wanted to do but i didn't want
to do something that you guys would
expect from me where they're all in
Gotham and it's with one artist and I
get used to that artists like jock I
wanted it to be like okay every story is
a challenge how do i do a villain in a
way you've never seen before in a story
that's completely different than any
kind of Batman story that you've read
and so the challenge was really just
doing something that was like Tom King
just making faces at me over there the
best writer in comics right over there I
know right the the challenge is really
to do something that you've never seen
in every villain and do them in a new
way so first up in the series is to face
with John Romita declan shalvey and
Jordy blared oohs ahhs and the backups
and everything is sort of like to face
on the road chained to Batman Batman's
trying to get him upstate like 500 miles
to give him a cure for being two-faced
and along the way to face makes this
terrible bet with the country he
releases this statement on the news that
basically sets everyone after Batman
it's almost like everyone's trying to
kill him my favorite thing is like you
open the book and Batman it's a diner
right it's this beautiful diner and the
people are just having breakfast and
joking around and all of a sudden Killer
Moth and and and Firefly come crashing
in with Batman and uh everyone's
terrified and killer brats like you tell
us where he is meaning to face or we'll
kill everyone in here in Batman's like
listen look at me people he's like no
one in here dies today mne winks and it
freezes on him and it's like Batman most
wanted man in the state and it's like
that's the feel of it where it's it's
fun it's high-octane but it's also a
very personal story it's this every one
of them is like Catwoman is in Savannah
they're all over there like it's all out
of Gotham but ultimately like this one
is largely about you know whether our
personal demons are more important to us
than we like to think whether we
are the sort of some of our ugliest
parts and the ugly side of our face and
the wishes we want to make and coins do
you want to throw into fountains that we
shouldn't or whether we're better people
than we then we think we are and
Batman's obviously betting on one side
and two faces betting on the other now
when you look at the different arcs and
a different artist you try to recruit a
specific artist for like the story like
okay I can't get them now so I'm going
to try to reschedule that story no i
I've been working on this thing honestly
because I thought maybe if Greg took a
break I started working on a long time
ago almost a year plus before Greg left
as maybe something to do on the side
with different artists and then I
realized no you know when he wanted to
leave I was like this is when he takes a
break this is where I want to go so it
really became about more asking what
what to each artist what's the character
you always wanted to draw a Mad Hatter
ok Paul Pope is that we want to do like
let's do it you know and and I sold
ramita I was like you know to face he's
kind of gritty he's up your alley he's
like well he's kind of cloudy and I'm
like not if we do him like this he's
like that's my guy let's do it cuz i was
like croc or this guy or what and
similarly like I was like to a fool who
would you like or you know maybe
Catwoman maybe and Tula was like poison
ivy poison ivy is mine I'm like great
she just said in her designs so it's
it's honestly about and jock was mr.
freeze up and down he's like I want like
the architect just ice and this figure
emerges it's great it's like Mr Freeze
wants to open up the oldest I score in
the world I'm just spoiling everything
the oldest I score in the world and just
poison the world it's really fun but
everyone is kind of a slight reinvention
of the villains in continuity the
designs are going to kind of become the
designs for the dcu so everything is
again in continuity and the backups I'll
tell the story of Duke Thomas's
ascension and a secret history sort of
of the robins and the training they went
through as he becomes kind of the hero
he's going to be can we expect any new
gadgets or toys for Batman yes in fact
in the first issue you will see new
gadgets like he uses his cape in a new
way and the first one which is really
fun and in the second one he uses a
Batarang we're basically I'm just gonna
spoil more Killer Croc he's not he's
fighting Killer Croc on a train and
killer croc's like that little Batarang
you think that's gonna do something to
me and batman throws it it's like gin
spikes come out of it it's
it's crazy violent but it's only mine
it's not violent like salacious
over-the-top violence it's meant to be
like the brutal reality of how ugly how
ugly people can be behind closed doors
so that's kind of the theme that kind of
runs through it and so all the brutality
and the violence is meant to sort of be
surprising in certain ways and happen in
very pastoral settings and anyway I love
it now a tiny bit of art has been
released like some cover isn't it it
looks a little brighter so is that
something like throughout the art with
Too Faced it's going to be brighter
instead of like Batman at night yeah
it's almost all in the day on the road
so the challenge was like how do you
make Batman look badass and the villains
look scary in like corn fields you know
in the middle of nowhere and then you
see John Romita zart and Danny Mickey's
inks and and and Dean's colors and it's
just like oh yeah they're scary it's
awesome one of the scenes is like
penguin at a gas station and it's not
funny it's not like a cartoony series at
all it's really dark but like at one
point penguin is chasing them with the
crime bosses and they stopped to talk on
the road and these guys make fun of
penguin and he just does the man really
bad but it's fun there at a gas station
I won't give it away i won't give it
away but it really is it's a brighter
book it's got like a very kinetic energy
it's cut the way its paste is cut very
differently it has mile markers as it
kind of moves along there it's really
I'm so proud of it honestly i would i
would definitely put it up against
anything I've done is one of the best
one of the best stories like this the
first arc at least in the second one
which i'm working on up there with my
best stuff you know i think so i hope
you guys agree now are you going with
shorter arcs rather than you know like
the year-long almost artists there's no
gonna know 24 issue arcs or anything if
they're all they're all pretty short the
longest the longest two were about four
to five issues the two-faced one and
Sean Murphy's big finale where it's a
mystery villain that I don't want to
give away it's all actually one story
when you kind of put it together in
three parts all leading up to its all
called my own worst enemy and it leads
up to someone pretty fun so you'll see
have you shown any of it to Greg and his
e like I show everything to Greg and he
shows me all the reborn stuff Greg just
we were just texting the other day and
he was like he there's no bigger fan of
ramita than then Greg and there's no
bigger fan of Greg than ramita they love
each other and so he was just like I'm
so glad he thinks he's doing the
work of his career ramita is and greg's
just handling it by the way on reborn
you got to pick that up the mark millar
book so good and then we get back
together he's done in November and we're
starting something really crazy bag like
really crazy big for DC so unless you
know I hope so now are we gonna be
surprised with what you guys I know
you're not going to say anything about
what it is but is it gonna be like a big
shock to everyone yeah I think it will
be I mean we're not coming back to do
Batman I'll tell you that likes that
would just be I feel like almost too
easy we want to try new challenges you
know like ad is the wild challenge for
me I'll star how do you top yourself or
at least do work that's so different
than what you've done that people think
it's worth the same you know the same
sort of scrutiny yeah and so what we do
when we come back I'll be really
different but bigger and yeah
intimidating I'm now nervous like
talking about it cuz I'm like it's gonna
be a lot but I love working with that
dude he's like a brother and I can't
wait okay so all sir Batman starts in
August and it's obviously gonna be new
reader friendly people just jump in you
know obviously if they know who Batman
is enjoy it ribbon is you don't even
have to know he is you there's actually
a caption that says batman most wanted
man in the state so you do not even know
have to know Batman is all the villains
have gaps like it's super user friendly
for new readers so so buy it buy it for
your friends bye-bye free for your mom
yeah for me for my kids all of it it'll
be good I promise I appreciate it let me
just say this like we just got the sales
the official initial sales on the book
and I sincerely all my joking aside like
I never thought it was going to sell
what it would it's selling already and
the fact that you guys have been that
supportive of me in this book and
experimenting and taking the bed will be
a little bit off road it just you never
cease to Humble us and we really really
cannot thank you enough it's honestly
it's an honor and and it just means the
world I have the best fans in the world
like back hands down best fans in the
world on my kids lives like we love you
guys so much all right make sure you
look for an all-star batman it's gonna
be awesome thanks
you